all right hi everyone
um welcome to the 224n python review
session
um the goal of the session really will
be to sort of give you the basics
um of python and numpy in particular
that you'll be using a lot in your
second homework
um and the homework will come after that
as well
um we're sort of taking this tutorial
from the background of anyone who hasn't
touched programming languages to some
extent
um but also for people who have will be
sort of going through a lot of that
material very quickly and we'll be
progressing to numpy as well
um and as I mentioned first and foremost
the session is really meant for the
people who are here in person so if
you'd like me to slow down speed up at
any point need time for clarifications
feel free to ask us and it's really
meant for you first um here and that I
really would like it to be sort of an
interactive session as well
all right so this is a topic the topics
we'll be covering today
um going through first of all why python
is a language why have we chosen it for
sort of discourse and in general why do
people prefer prefer it to some extent
for machine learning and natural
language processing
um some basics of the language itself
common data structures and then getting
to sort of the meat of it through numpy
which as I mentioned you'll be
extensively using in your homeworks
going forward and then some practical
tips about how to use
um things in Python
all right it's first thing why python um
so a lot of you who might have um been
first introduced to programming might
have done Java before a lot of people
use Matlab in
um other in other fields as well
um so why python python is generally
used um for one because it's a very high
level language um it can look very very
english-like and so it's really easy to
work with for people especially when
they get started out it has a lot of
scientific computational functionality
as well similar to Matlab so when you
talk about numpy you'll see that it has
a lot of framework so very very quick
and efficient operations involving math
or matrices and that's very very useful
in applications such as deep learning
and for deep learning in particular a
lot of Frameworks that people use
particularly for example Pi torch and
tensorflow interface directly with
python and so for that those main
reasons people generally tend to use
Python within deep learning
okay so the setup information is in the
slides if you like to look at them
offline
um I will be sort of jumping over that
for now because I want to sort of get to
the introduction to the language itself
and if you have time come back to sort
of the setup information a lot of it's
pretty direct you can walk through it um
it gives you steps for sort of how to
install packages
um what is a conda environment for
example and gets you set up with your
first working python environment so you
can sort of run simple and basic
commands to get used to the language but
for now I'm going to be skipping over
this and coming back to it if we have
time
all right language Basics so
um in Python you have variables and
these variables can take on multiple
values the assignment operation there's
an equal sign will allow you to assign
this particular value to a variable a
nice thing with python is you don't have
to instantiate the type of the variable
to begin with and then only instantiate
or only assign values of that type so
for example in certain languages we
first say that this variable X is only
going to be of type intent any value
aside from that assigned to it will
throw an error Python's pretty flexible
so if I want to I can reassign it I can
start with X is equal to 10 and then
later on like five lines later I can say
x is equal to high as a string and there
would be no issue
um you can do simple mathematical
operations such as the plus and division
signs you can do exponentiation which is
Raising one value to another value so x
to the power of Y for example using the
double asterisk
um you can do type castings for float
division so if you want to ensure that
your values are being divided resulting
in a float value and not just dividing
two integers you can cast two different
types like float if you want something
to be explicitly an INT you can also
just put an INT instead of the float
with brackets around the result and
that'll give you an integer value and
then you can also do typecasting to for
example convert from integers to Strings
so in this case if I wanted to instead
of doing 10 plus 3 as a mathematical
operation I just want to write out 10
plus 3 then I can convert the X and Y
values for example to Strings and then
add the plus sign as as a character as
well to create a string and so a lot of
these common operations you can look
online as well people have lists for
them and just see how they're sort of
dot in Python
all right
um some other quick things um so Boolean
values the the true and the false um
they're always used with capital letters
and some of the languages they might be
lowercase so just one thing to know
um python also doesn't have a null value
the equivalent of a null value is none
so sometimes when you want to say that
this value you want to return none
saying I'm not really doing anything
here you want to do checks protect for
example in if statements
um to say that this doesn't have a value
then you can assign it to none so none
sort of functions as a null equivalent
so you're not really returning anything
it doesn't have a value not the same as
zero and um another nice thing about
python is lists which are sort of um
mutable we'll come to that a little bit
later but sort of mutable lists of
objects that means that you can change
them they can be of any type so you can
have a mixture of integers non-values
strings
Etc
and yeah functions can return the
non-value as well
um and another quick thing instead of
using the double and and uh in some of
the languages as people might do with
python I mentioned earlier it's very
english-like so you can actually just
write out
um if x is equal to three and and in
English Y is equal to four then return
true or something
um it's it's quite nice that way so you
can use and or and not
um and then just the comparison
operators of equal equals to and not
equal to we'll check for equality and
inequality this one's pretty standard I
feel across many languages and you can
use them in python as well
and yeah remember just clicking the
equal equal to sign is different from
the assignment operator this one checks
for equality that one is just assigning
a value
so single equal sign versus two of them
all right and then also in Python you
don't use brackets so python you can use
basically spaces or tabs so either
indents of two or four to be able to
break up what is contained in the
function or contained within like an if
statement a for statement
um or any Loops for example
um and so the main thing is you can
choose whether to do two or four you
just have to be consistent throughout
your entire
um code base otherwise they will throw
an error
now go to some common data structures
and for this we'll transition to the
collab
so this will sort of show you in real
time this is by the way a collab a
collab is basically um a Jupiter
notebook for those of you who are
familiar with those
um that you can use that it's hosted on
Google servers
um the really nice thing about jupyter
notebooks is you don't have to run an
entire file altogether you can run it
step by step into what are these called
cells so if you want to see like an
intermediate output you can see that
pretty easily and that way and Indian
also writes for example a lot of um like
descriptions
um pertaining to cells which is really
really nice to have as well so a lot of
people like tend to use these when
they're sort of starting off the project
we want to debug things and colab allows
you to use these jupyter notebook type
applications hosted on their servers for
free basically so anyone can create one
of these and run their code
all right so lists are mutable arrays
mutable means that you can change them
so that once you declare them you can
add to them you can delete them and
they're optimized for that purpose so
they expect to be changed very often
we'll come to what are called numpy
arrays later and those tend to be pretty
much fixed when you create a new one
you'd have when you change one you'd
basically have to create a new array
um which will have the additional
information so this is highly optimized
for changing things so if you know for
example and you're in a loop you're
adding different elements to let's say a
bigger entity you'd want to use
something like a list because you're
going to be changing that very often so
let's see how they work so we start off
with a names array with Zach and J
um you can index into the list
um by so what is this index into the
list by index which means that you can
um
list out the elements in the list um
depending on What's called the index so
it's what place that value is at within
the list so zero refers to the first
element so Python's what's called zero
index which means it starts with zero
and then it goes to one so here zero
will be Zack
and then let's say I want to append
something to the end so the to add
something to the end of the list the
term is append not add and so if I want
to append
I can now create a separate list which
is the original list itself with the
added last element
and what would currently be the length
of this it would be three because you
have three elements and you can just
quickly get that by using the Len
function not length just three letters
Len
all right
um it's also really nice because python
has overloaded the plus
operation to be able to concatenate
lists so here I have a separate list
right and all you need for a list
definition is just brackets so this is a
separate list altogether even though I
haven't saved it in the variable just
Abby and Kevin and I can just do a plus
equal to which means that names is equal
to names plus Abby and Kevin and this
should output this full list
you can create lists by just putting the
plain brackets or an existing list and
then as I mentioned earlier your list
can have a variety of types within them
so here this list contains an integer
value a list value so you can have a
list of lists as many sort of sub lists
as you like a float value and a none
value
and this is completely valid within
python
slicing refers to how you can access
only parts of the list so if I only want
for example
um in this numbers array I only want 0 1
2 slicing is a way that you can extract
only those parts so the way sizing works
is the first element is included and the
last element is excluded so here I start
with 0 1 2 3. so 3 is not included and
so 0 1 2 will be printed out there's
also shorthands so if you know that
you're going to be starting with the
first element of the arrays if you know
I'm starting I want zero one two and it
starts with zero then you don't need to
even include the first index you can
just leave that and include the last
index that would be excluded so that
would be blank semicolon 3 and same deal
with the end if you know that you want
to take everything let's say from like
five and six till the end of the array
you can start with what would you like
so 0 1 2 3 4 5 till the end and leave
that oh sorry
um fun fact so this um semicolon when
you take this just the semicolon it'll
take everything in the list but it'll
also create a duplicate in memory that's
that's a very slight
um very useful thing to to know
um because sometimes when you're like
past Less in an array uh sorry in Python
which is out of scope of this tutorial
um you can only pass the reference to it
so if you will change the array that
gets changed this will create an
entirely separate copy in memory of the
exact same array so if you make any
changes to it it won't affect your
original array so this is a very pretty
neat way to do that
um and then another fun thing that
python has which is pretty unique is you
can index negatively so negative
indexing means you index from the back
of the array so -1 refers to the last
element of the array minus three will
refer to the third last element and so
what minus one will give you will be six
in this case when minus three will give
you will be everything because you're
starting with the minus three elements
so minus one minus two minus three till
the end and then this one seems kind of
confusing right three to minus two so
this will do is it will give you 0 1 2 3
so you start with three and then minus
one minus two so you leave off the X the
last because you excluded within list
um you'd only get three and four so
that's what this is
okay that's about lists
tuples are immutable arrays so once you
declare the values of these they cannot
be changed so I start with remember we
started with like the list of Zach and
Jay tuples you start with Zach and Jay
um and you can still access them you
know I can still print out name zero
same as I did with lists but if I try to
change it in this case it'll throw an
error so two pulls once you've
instantiated them they cannot be changed
and to create an empty Tuple you just
create you can either use just a tuple
sign or oftentimes you can just use the
parentheses backwards so you can just
say for example as you did here just
parentheses to instantiate something
all right
and yeah this one we'll we'll come to a
little bit later in shapes but you can
also have a tuple of a single value and
all you have to do there is just put the
value and put a comma so that just shows
that you have a tuple which is like with
like an immutable array so you can't
change it it's a list but only of one
item
and that's here
okay I'll quickly move to dictionaries
um for those of you who might be
familiar with other languages this is
the equivalent of like a hash map or
hash table
um what this is useful for essentially
is mapping one value to another in a
really really quick way
um so if I want to map for example a
string to an index which you will happen
to do a lot of in your homeworks
um this is a really really useful way to
do that and so what what it does is you
can instantiate this dictionary and it
says corresponding that DAC is going to
correspond to the string value whatever
it is and so anytime I want to retrieve
the string value I just use this
dictionary I indexed by it which is what
I do here and then it outputs the
corresponding value and it does that
really really quickly
um and yeah so it's really useful very
very commonly used especially when you
sort for example you have like a list of
strings or a list of items and you want
to have a corresponding index for them
because and as you'll see in NLP
oftentimes you're using what you're
working with indices and numbers in
particular so it's a really great way to
sort of move from like string formats to
just like um numerical index values
there's some other things you can do for
dictionaries you can check whether
certain elements are in there so if you
for example try to index phone book is
equal to monsie they'll throw an error
because there's no string that says
Monty in that phone book dictionary and
so sometimes you might be wanting to do
checks before you extract a value and so
this will just check for example if I do
print monsie and phone book it should
say false or for example here Kevin and
phone book it should say false while
something that's actually in that
dictionary Zach will be true
okay and then if you'd like to delete an
entry from the um from the dictionary
you can just do that using the Dell
command
all right let's move to Loops
um quickly so Loops are a really great
way to optimize for the same kind of app
same kind of operation you're doing it's
also a great way to
um start to sequentially go over those
list type or array type objects we were
talking about earlier you know you have
like a list of names right how do you
access all of them so Loops are a really
great way to do that
um in Python they've abstracted away a
lot of the confusing sort of
um parts and other languages that might
be you can really for example first
index on numbers so what you do is you
have like a range function that you call
so here you say range and the range of
the last number you'd want so with this
range function will return is 0 1 2 3 4
and that's what will be stored in this I
value and here it's just printing out
that I value
so if I wanted for example Loop over the
length of a list of size 10 I just have
to do 4i and range 10 and then index
that corresponding part of the list you
technically don't even have to do that
because in Python you can just directly
get the element of the list so here I
have an a list of
um names where I have Zac J and Richard
instead of saying first the length of
the list and then doing this range
operation I can just directly say for
name and names and then print out the
names and it will just directly get the
element in each list
but sometimes you might want both you
might both want this element Zach as
well as its position in the array and
for that you can actually use this
really helpful function called enumerate
and so enumerate will basically pair
those two values and it'll give you the
both the value which is here name for
example and its corresponding index
within the array both together so that's
really really convenient versus for
example having to do this like a little
bit more complicated range operation
where you first take the range and then
you index the US
how do you iterate over a dictionary so
for dictionaries if you want to enter
um iterate over What's called the keys
so all of these first items that you
first you know put into the dictionary
you can just iterate the same way you
would a list you just say foreign name
and for example phone book and you can
output the keys if you want to iterate
over what is stored in the list which is
called a value you'd have to do the
dictionary dot values and if you want
both you use the dot items function and
so that will print out both of these
all right
so this is sort of covering the
overarching most commonly used sort of
structures lists dictionaries and then
loops and how to sort of efficiently use
them within your code
we'll quickly be moving to the sort of
meat of what um is really really strong
about Python and what you'll be using a
lot for your coming homework essentially
homework 2 which is numpy
okay so for numpy also I'm going to be
going to the collab we just quickly
wanted to mention
um what numpy is so numpy is basically
an optimized Library
um for mathematical operations you know
people tend to like math lab because
it's very very useful for these
mathematical operations which people use
in their research
um pythons sort of solution to that is
to have a separate Library entirely
where they make use of subroutines which
are sort of like sub languages sorry sub
scripts that are written in a different
language called C or C plus plus that
are highly optimized for efficiency so
the reason C and C plus plus are much
faster than python is because they're
closer to what's called machine language
which is what the computer will read I
mentioned earlier one of the nice things
about python is it's kind of high level
it looks like English right to some
extent you know we say literally like is
you know if x is equal to one or X is
equal to two right but um that also
means that there's a lot more
translation required on the computer's
part before it understands what you mean
um and that's useful when you know we're
writing out code where we want under
understand it but it's a little bit less
useful when you're sort of running a lot
of operations on a lot of data so the
real benefit of something like lumpy is
that if you have sort of your memory and
your data in a particular format it'll
call the these like species scripts or
what are called subroutines in a
different language and it'll make them
very very fast and so that's the real
benefit of using numpy and almost
everyone
um in in sort of NLP is very very
familiar with this because you'll be
running a lot of operations on for
example like co-occurrence matrices
which are really really big and
um it's very useful to have them
optimized for time so that's really the
benefit of using numpy
and numpy basically it's involved for
all these like math and Matrix and
Vector calculations and it's different
than a list although you can easily
translate between a list and a numpy
array numpy arrays are specifically as I
mentioned designed to be used in these
subroutines so they have a specific
format they're instantiated differently
and you can translate between this and
sort of your standard lists easily but
to know that you can only do numpy
operations on numpy arrays you can't do
numpy operations on lists directly you'd
first have to like convert them which is
really simple you just use this
numpy.array function but just know that
they operate only on numpy arrays
okay so for numpy we're going to be
going back to the collab
and then as I mentioned earlier the real
strength of numpy is you know it
supports these large multi-dimensional
arrays and matrices for very very
optimized high-level mathematical
functions
um and just to go back step back for a
quick second what is a matrix matrices
are basically like rectangular
um structures of numbers that are used
and you can treat them with specific
rules
um for operations between different
kinds of things so if you have like a
lot of data instead of you know
individually potentially multiplying
things if you can store them in this
rectangular format you have specific
rules about how this Matrix for example
interact with a different one and by
doing that which is matrix
multiplication or Matrix math
um you can do a wide variety of
mathematical operations a vector is
generally this is conventional none of
these are like hard and fast rules but
conventionally a vector is a matrix in
one dimension so it's usually like a row
vector or a column Vector which usually
just means that it's a list of values
and only one mentioned so it's like for
example here when I come down to X is
equal to numpy array of one two three
that's a listen only one dimension
versus for example Z when I this is z
down here that is what's called like a
two-dimensional array because you have
both rows for example like six comma
seven and then you have eight comma nine
um versus in this first one you only
have three values in one dimension so
that's sort of the conventional
difference between the two another
convention is matrices generally
referred to two-dimensional objects so
this as I mentioned is like Z this is
two dimensional you might have heard the
word tensor also tensors by convention
usually are like higher dimensional
objects so instead of having two
Dimensions you know two comma two you
can have like n Dimensions you can have
two comma two comma two comma two comma
two for like five or six dimensions and
those are very valid to do mathematical
operations on
um and those are often colloquially sort
of called tensors in addition and this
will be covered in the next tutorial in
pi torch
um those larger sort of tensors are also
optimized for efficiency
um to be used on gpus and so they're
called tensor in a more concrete way
because you're using these tensors with
pytorch and other sort of packages to
directly do those quicker GPU operations
on for deep learning so those are sort
of this is a quick sort of terminology
difference between the three
okay so now
um let's start off with just some quick
sort of representations of how are these
matrices and vectors represented in
numpy
um this sort of goes back to your
question about like what is the
difference between like three comma
versus like one comma three
um so usually three comma and numpy
arrays usually just means that you have
one list of like one two three for
example there's like three values versus
if you add another list on top of that
this one comma 3 essentially refers to
the fact that there's a list of lists so
anytime you have two Dimensions it
always means that there's a list of
lists
um and that being like a list of lists
for example like a row so here one comma
three means that there's one row and
then three columns so it's saying
there's one row of three comma four
comma five essentially and then each of
those is a column separately
you can easily reshape them so these are
basically the same format but from
numpy's perspective you'll see a little
bit later for operations such as
broadcasting you need to have it for
example sometimes in this one comma
three format or three comma one format
um and also like
what like as I said three is this he
just like she represents three numbers
one comma three means like one row of
three elements three comma one will mean
you have essentially in each column
you'll have a separate array so you'll
see sort of boxes around each of them
there's an example that comes a little
bit later in this collab which will make
it a little bit more clearer so here if
you can see the difference between like
X and Y one of them has only one bracket
which just says it's one list only one
list of one comma two comma three the
second one is two brackets which says
it's a list with only one list in it if
it's a list of a list that's really the
main difference between like these sort
of two representations so I could have
like let's say like a separate
one I'm going to call this a and I just
do this
so it's the same sort of elements but
this will be one comma three because
it's showing that there's one outer list
which shows the rows and then one inner
list which I like to have each of those
values
so the benefit will when I'm coming to
what's a little bit later which is
broadcasting and so it essentially will
help you determine what dimensions you
want to match against because sometimes
you'd want to have one comma three like
one comma two comma three applied only
two rows in some other Matrix well we'll
come to that a little bit later
um but sometimes you might want to have
it only applied to columns and so like
if I have a separate Matrix for example
of zero zero zero zero zero zero zero
zero and I want the resulting Matrix to
be for example one two three one two
three one two three along the rows let
me actually draw this out it might be
easier
so
let's say I have like the zero zero zero
zero zero zero zero zero
and if I want to have a matrix that does
one two three one two three one two
three versus
three
the difference in how to generate these
two
um will be the difference in the shape
like how you represent their shape it's
the same one two three but the resulting
array you're generating by repeating the
one two three values
um requires a difference in shape and so
we'll come to that a little bit later
because this process of how do you
generate these arrays is called
broadcasting but that's the real benefit
of having an understanding of the shapes
the same one two three values are the
same it's just how they're sort of used
with regards to other arrays
all right so yeah vectors can be usually
represented as sort of and this is what
I talked about earlier as like n
Dimensions n by one or one by n
dimensions and they can result in this
different Behavior kind of what like
this that I talked about
um matrices are usually in two
Dimensions represented as M by n
um these are just two examples if for
example I generate let's say an engine
also reshape so I start with for example
this array
which is a list of 10 oh sorry it's
important on Pi quickly
so I start off with this Matrix a which
is basically a one-dimensional list of
ten values I can reshape it into a five
by two Matrix so you just have to make
sure that your Dimensions match which
means that like you can multiply them
together and get the original size so if
I start off with the 10 matrix I can
make a two by five Matrix I can make a
five by two Matrix I can make a ten by
one one by ten I can't make it for
example three and five because that it
wouldn't fit into the original size
um and for that this operation called
reshape is really useful
um you might be wondering why is there
two parentheses the way that reshape
works is essentially it'll take in a
tuple so remember that what I was
talking about earlier with tuples is
that these they're immutable objects and
they're defined by parentheses so the
outer parenthesis is representing what
you're inputting to the function and
what you're inputting is a tuple so it
uses a second set of parentheses
so now let's go to some array operations
um so I started off with you know this
array X
um when you apply simple operations for
example a Max operation sometimes you
might want the max of the entire array
so if I do the max of in the entire
array what's the max value of the entire
array by the way just the entire thing
six right so if I just do NP dot Max of
X it'll return one value and return six
but let's say I want the max of every
row right like and every in each of
these rows I say I want let's say the
max of each I want two and then four and
then six how do you do that and so numpy
always has like usually in most of their
functions an access variable and what
the axis variable will do is it'll tell
you which of these Dimensions do you
want to take the max over
and the way to sort of think about it is
this is going to be a little bit tricky
but the way people describe it is the
access is what you want to apply your
function over what you want to reduce
over and what that means is I print out
the shape of the original array it's
three by two
I want to apply access one or as I
remember you know numpy is zero indexed
it'll be zero one so I want to apply the
max over the second dimension the second
dimension means that for each of these
essentially you know that like for like
the row Dimension is the First Dimension
so it's not around along the rows I'm
going to be comparing columns and so
compare this entire column to this
entire column
and so just remember for axes
um usually the axis zero refers to the
row axis and then axis one refers to the
column access
um if you don't even want to remember
that you can just remember that from the
original Dimension which of these it's
referring to
um and that's the dimension you want to
compare over or reduce over
so it can be a little bit harder to
grasp around it usually the best way to
sort of get around is like just play
with a bunch of sort of operations of
min max and things like that but just
remember like the access is what you
want to compare over not the resulting
thing so axis one means here column I
want to compare between the columns I
want to get for example comparing one to
two three to four five to six
does that make sense
okay
and what this will do is if I just do
numpy.axis it'll just return basically
since I'm comparing these columns it'll
just return a resultant column and so as
I mentioned you know um for over the
axis one you get three values because
you're comparing over these columns and
each column has three values I'm
comparing over rows as you mentioned I
get two values right
um and so this will just be the Tuple
comma which is just indicating that it's
just a list it's not a list of lists
it's just a list but let's say I want a
list of lists you know maybe I want to
do those operations I talked about
earlier
um instead of reshaping which is always
there it's always an option you can also
use this um feature called keep dimms
and what that'll do is it'll take the
original Dimensions which is two
Dimensions right because you have three
comma two just two of them and it'll
keep that consistent so it'll be three
comma one
but it just means that instead of
returning just the extracted column
which is just a list it'll basically
keep the column in the context of the
original sort of X and it'll be it'll
keep it as like a two-dimensional value
all right
now these are just some operations so in
numpy
um you can use an asterisk as a an
element-wise multiplication so an
asterisk means that I'm going to be
comparing every single value
um to every single corresponding value
in another Matrix and it's you need your
matrices to also be the same size for
this one so this one it's basically an
element wise matrix it's not a matrix
multiplication so you need to have them
be the exact same size so this will
compare for example one into three two
into three three into three and four
into three
all right
um you can also do matrix multiplication
which is a different operation entirely
um for those of you unfamiliar with
matrix multiplication
um you would basically be multiplying a
row of one Matrix with the column of
another Matrix and for that to be
necessary you need to have the second
dimension of the first array be equal to
the first dimension of the second array
so for matrix multiplication if I have
an
a and two B comma 3 in tune c
um shaped matrices these two have to be
equal for matrix multiplication just
something to keep in mind because
oftentimes if you're doing matrix
multiplication
um you need you have to make sure these
dimensions are the same which means that
for example
this is a valid operation
um but this can sometimes throw an error
sometimes so it's just important to make
sure that sometimes you you want to make
sure that these are exactly equal you
can actually just print out the shapes
and make sure that these are equal to be
doing matrix multiplication and then for
matrix multiplication
um there's a couple of
functions you can use the first one is
just np.mat mule which is NP dot matrix
multiplication you can also just use the
um the at operation and that one both of
those are overloaded you can choose
whichever one they'll result in the same
exact operation and just a quick session
show you can to show what this will do
is we'll multiply one into two so it'll
come like one two versus three four so
it'll do one into three two into three
and add those two values so that's what
matrix multiplication will do
okay and then dot products will what
what a DOT product is that it takes two
vectors so usually it operates on
vectors and a vector as I mentioned is
just like a one-dimensional matrix so
it's just basically Three cross one for
example a four cross one
um it'll element wise multiply between
two different vectors and we'll sum up
those values and so here what a DOT
product do would be like one into one
plus two into ten plus three into a
hundred and for a numpy you can just do
NP Dot and then both of those vectors
um this one is just a side on how you
would want the structure of the dot
product to be
um for arrays that are more so okay so
the phrase is the best way
um for single dimensional vectors this
operation Works directly anytime it's a
multiple dimensional Matrix
um then it treats it as a matrix
multiplication the NP dot dot function
so for two by two Matrix versus a two by
two Matrix dot product it's not going to
return the sum it's going to return
um the matrix multiplication so that's
just something to keep in mind if you
want to make sure that your your dot
product is happening in the correct way
you would want to make sure that sort of
similar to what I was talking about
earlier that
here this is I think the best way best
way to show it
okay so you would want the second like
that what I mentioned like the last
dimension of the first one to match with
the first dimension of the next one
because it's treating it as like a
matrix multiplication
um here the error that it's throwing is
it's three comma two combined with three
and so the way to sort of like fix that
would be to have this be like for
example like
um switch the two so you have two comma
three and then three comma
it's really a dimension matching thing
at this point so it's it can be a little
bit confusing but when you sort of the
main thing to keep in mind is like for
single dimensional vectors you can just
do NP dot dot directly and they'll give
you the dot product value for higher
dimensional matrices it treats it as a
matrix multiplication
um and so for if you still want to like
for those higher dimensional values to
ensure that you're getting a DOT product
um you'd have to make sure that the
dimensions are aligned similar to these
so anything that's two by two plus for
both
um any any Matrix who doesn't have a
single dimension in any of them yes it
would treat it as a matrix matte Neil
the same thing
okay
all right um okay I'm going to move to
indexing so similar to what I was
talking about earlier remember with list
I was saying if you just do the
semicolon it'll create like the same
array same deal here the the semicolon
just means that you take everything from
the original array in fact it returns a
copy so it returns a deep copy means if
you have a completely separate copy in
memory
um okay now I'm going into sort of more
details about how do you want to index
quickly so if I for example have let's
say this three by four Matrix and I only
want to select the zero and the second
rows how would I do that
so what's useful is that you can sort of
treat a numpy you can treat different
dimensions differently for indexing so a
semicolon means you select everything in
that Dimension which for example here
there's a semicolon in the second
dimension which means I'm taking all of
the column values
um versus what's in the First Dimension
here it's saying a numpy array of zero
and two so it's saying only the zero
index and only the two index which means
only the zero would throw and only the
second row so what this would look like
would be something like
I have a matrix
okay I have a matrix and I only want to
select the zeroth row and I only want to
select the column the second row 0 and
second and everything in the columns
all right
and then similarly for example if I want
to select in the column Dimension
um I want to select the first and second
rows at only the first row I can do that
so you can basically treat them
separately you can think how many
columns do I want how many rows do I
want and then index so separately and
that goes for as many dimensions as you
want in your entire tensor
um some nice things also if I want to
for example take it I have this like let
me print that actually X here I'll just
generate the X
okay so this is X right so if I want to
take all the values of X that are above
0.5 for example I can do that by using
what's called Boolean indexing so I just
basically would say x indexed by
everything in X that's bigger than 0.5
so it's pretty direct and it'll just
output all the values in this entire
array that are bigger than 0.5
all right this one is also another way
to do reshaping so I kind of mentioned
earlier you know sometimes you won't
have this like list of three elements
and you want to reshape it to a three by
one array for example you can also use
what's called numpy.new access this will
essentially add another access
in whatever Dimension you want so if I
want to change go from like this three
by four array to a three by
three by four two three by four by one
then I can just add a numpy.nu axis
there an even simpler way to think about
it would be like a 2 comma
to uh two comma one and so it's just
it's another way to do what essentially
what would be the reshape reshaping
operation
does that make sense also what this
would look like for example let me just
a little bit more concrete
this is
so as we see I have this list right I
have like a singular list and then each
in in that list I have a list of lists
so I have a list with element one and
list of element two so this is what that
reshape operation will do
and what numpy.new access will enable
you to do as well
all right
um I think we are a good time um so the
last main topic we'll be covering is
broadcasting
um and what's really great about
broadcasting is it'll allow you to
operate with numpy arrays that are of
different shapes but can be sort of with
many operations in them can be repeated
it allows for that in a very efficient
manner and this is actually one of the
most I would say useful things about
numpy and one of its defining features
and what that means is
um if for example in this case right if
we go back to this example that I had
with I start off with the zero zero zero
array how do I generate this array
versus how do I generate this array
right instead of me saying okay element
zero zero plus one element zero one plus
two all that stuff right instead of
doing that one by one what broadcasting
allows me to do is I can have only one
vector of size one two three
and it'll depending on how I do the
broadcasting which I'll come to in a
second I can duplicate it along the row
Dimension or I can duplicate it along
the column Dimension and numpy allows
for that it'll do that on its own in the
back end
and so that's really what broadcasting
means is I don't need to for example
create a new array saying I want to like
create a new array to begin with which
is already like this and then add those
two together I can just duplicate this
and get this
all right so now some rules for
broadcasting and let me just quickly
visually also just show what
broadcasting will do oh sorry
so broadcasting this is a pretty good
visual analogy
um I had this one by one comma one comma
two comma three Vector right
um and I wanna basically add let's say
only the columns with this one comma two
comma 3 Vector so what broadcasting
allows you to do is you'll you only pass
these two values in and on the back end
it'll duplicate this along the column
Dimension so let's say I have one two
three one two three one two three one
two three and then it'll do the addition
similarly if I pass it a vector one
comma two comma three comma four and I
want it to be added to each of the rows
instead of each of the columns it'll be
able to do that by sort of duplicating
it on the back end so this is visually
what's happening with Broadcasting
all right
now some rules so how does numpy know
when and how to do broadcasting so the
main two rules to keep in mind with for
broadcasting is one
um it can only happen if all of the
dimensions every single Dimension
between two arrays are compatible and
when they say what is compatible either
the dimension values are equal or one of
them is equal to one and that is the
only rule required so for example I
start off with this x array right I have
this like a three by four x array
um will Y is equal to three comma 1 be
compatible
yes it will be why because you have
three in the First Dimension between the
two which is the same and in the second
dimension you have four and you have one
so those are compatible values and so
what this tells numpy on the back end is
I'm doing for example an addition
Operation X Plus y it knows that okay
three and three are the same but four
and one are not the same you know one of
them has one dimension so I need to
duplicate this y along the second
dimension which means I need to
duplicate it along the column Dimension
and once it does that it duplicates it
it'll get four three comma four in Array
and then it can do the addition and it
does that really fast so it's better to
use broadcasting in this way but then
for you to create a separate array
already duplicated and then add them
similarly I have this Z array which is
one comma four
what x into Z will do is first I'll
check okay three comma one okay is that
compatible yes because you have three in
one dimension you have one in the second
and four and four are compatible okay so
say I know that these two are compatible
in the second dimension I'm going to
change anything in the First Dimension
it'll know to duplicate them basically
so in order to duplicate Z and so add it
three times in the row Dimension create
a separate array and then multiply those
two
so this is giving you an example of
saying I started off with X I have y and
then the final shape will be three comma
four so a lot of times in deep learning
um you will have the same
um
because you'll have different batches of
different images coming in but you want
to apply let's say the same weight
Matrix to all of them and instead of
duplicating that weight Matrix a hundred
or even like potentially depending on
the size of your batch size like a
thousand times and then adding those
together you use the same Matrix and
it'll know okay if I'm going to be
duplicating over the batch Dimension
it'll do that for you on the back end so
it's use a lot of times in deep learning
because of this and basically in your
second homework that's basically what
you'll be doing implementing a feed
floral Network in numpy and it'll say
you have like this W Matrix yeah this
like B Matrix which is a by we'll come
to those in class and it'll ask you to
implement their numpy because that's
basically what you're doing is if you
have this input image you have a weight
Matrix which will somehow scale it to an
output and that weight Matrix will be
applied to multiple images in your batch
and those images can be different but
their sizes will be the same and it's
optimized for that
okay
um so this is just more examples of sort
of the same thing your final thing that
you'll be coming to is a size of three
comma four
um let's see this one's sort of the
example that I showed right here right
which is that I have this array of
flight say zeros I have this numpy like
this B array of size what size were they
would this be yes good because you have
one outer list and inside this you have
one inner list so it's just basically
one row and then three values inside so
yes and so would this be compatible yes
and so it'll know basically to duplicate
um over the row Dimension and so you're
going to get duplicates in the row
Dimensions you're going to get one two
three one two three one two three and
that's what's Happening Here
um so these are for example a little bit
sometimes when it says more complex
um Behavior what this basically just
means is that like if I have this B
Vector which is three comma one
if I'm doing this B plus b dot transpose
by the transpose is just changing the
dimensions and switching them so if I
have a two by three Matrix uh transpose
will be a three by two Matrix
um what that means visually is something
like
your row and rows and like column
Dimensions will get switched
six goes to I believe it's like one two
three four five six so like three row
rows versus like three columns
um and what this is just saying is that
uh a three by one and a one by three
um both of those vectors will be
compatible because remember in each
Dimension it's either the same or one
and so it knows to duplicate uh over
both of those dimensions and that's
what's Happening Here
uh okay so I think we are right at time
um and what I would recommend is
basically playing with variations of
this for broadcasting and see December
the two rules for broadcasting is just
if it's compatible it's either the same
value or it's one and whatever is the
one dimension is what's going to be
duplicated over on the back end so yeah
it's not going to be compatible if
they're divisible for example right so
if you have like let's say six and three
that's not compatible
um you can reshape it and then see if
you'd like to have one there's tricks
you can use
um where you're sort of thinking like on
the back end how do I want this data to
be multiplied you can maybe reshape
everything into like an eight one like
one by eighteen Matrix and then multiply
everything and then reshape it back
that's what you can do but you can never
just directly for example six by three
make that compatible
okay
um so I think let's wrap up this one's
just a quick example of another use of
efficient numpy code
um quick note never preferably don't use
uh Loops whenever you're dealing with
large data matrices mostly because Loops
are almost always about a hundred times
slower numpy is usually very very
efficient as this is just an example of
what you can accomplish with numpy and
same thing using Loops so what this is
saying is that I have an X Matrix of
size thousand by thousand and I want to
apply you know let's say I want to add
everything from row 100 onwards
um with a plus five so visually what
that will look like is something like
I have this full Matrix and I wanted
everything here basically to be add with
plus added with plus five
um then in in the loop format I can
basically Loop over the First Dimension
um of 100 plus and do that or numpy I
can basically do what's called numpy.a
range which will generate um integers in
like we see one two three four five six
all the way up to that hundred value in
this case it's between hundred and
thousands let's start with hundred
hundred one hundred two all the way two
thousand in the First Dimension and then
just add that with five
so this is just an example of how you
would switch from using Loops to using
numpy and it's a lot lot faster